et fils votre père risque de ne plus
pouvoir parler à s'alimenter mercure
efforts physiques tout autre
[Musique]
sentant d'accord rien de toute façon
c'est à toi qui va mener
c'est un mauvais père
bliss l'aiment j'aurais adoré la voir
que rémy alors être lus comme une amie
en france c'est pas possible puisque en
plus j'ai pris contact avec une
association suisse mais il faudrait
aller là-bas très peu plus mince au
bonjour je suis ravi de parler avec vous
de tout s'est bien passé de france 11
alors est-ce que tout s'est bien passé
pour moi non tout ne s'est pas bien
passé parce que je suis sorti bouleversé
mais finalement c'est aussi ce qu'on
cherche au cinéma il s'est bien passé
merci pour ce petit bijou qui est un
film qui m'a transporté moi j'aimerais
savoir ce que vous avez ressenti vous à
la lecture du scénario
un scénario il manque plus qu pardon
mais les acteurs pour l'incarner donc on
projette beaucoup de choses on est quand
même dans la vision d'un metteur en
scène que j'ai découvert je vais jamais
tourné avec ozon et donc je me suis j'ai
marché dans la trace de ses pieds et
j'ai essayé d'être au plus près de ce
qu'ils désiraient et puis après il ya la
magie à la magie quand toutes ces
énergies se mettent ensemble les acteurs
tout le monde
après apparaît le film est là on le
découvre gelé oui c'est un film très
émouvant ce intime qui vous qui vous
prend là qui vous fait rire temps de
pleurer c'est très riche en en humanité
en s'agit je sais que françois ozon
voulait travailler avec vous depuis
longtemps c'était ce projet le bon pour
vous écouter on se pose pas la question
parce qu'en fait c'est celui pour
lesquels on sait à ce moment-là
retrouver qu'on a eu le désir de le
faire ensemble
il nous a fallu quelques années quelques
films vous savez françois il aime
tellement les acteurs qu' il ne leur en
veux pas et pourtant les metteurs en
scène je peux comprendre je l'étais
aussi un peu metteur en scène et quand
un acteur vous dis non
bon d'abord c'est un peu grâce à vous le
dites mais par qui le remplacer mais au
final je pense que l'acteur il a
toujours raison
parce qu'il ne peut pas aller à reculons
dans un film x y aller à 100% quoi et
finalement il faut y aller que pour les
bonnes raisons
c'est une grande carrière est faite de
choix aussi et en quoi on a le temps il
a ses films à faire moi aussi et puis en
tout cas c'est super rencontre vraiment
et je lui suis très reconnaissant que
parce que parce qu'il a il a fait un
très très beau film et c'est un très
très beau personnage
alors pour rappeler que c'est l'histoire
d'emmanuel berne m d'après son récit
autobiographique donc elle a accompagné
son père équipement qui désirait mettre
fin à ses jours dans la dignité
et quand lui l'avait choisi et vous
jouer ce rôle
comment est-ce qu'on aborde un rôle
comme celui ci alors qu'avec quelqu'un
qui avait qui a existé une histoire
qu'il faut s'approprier en même temps
oui enfin vous savez emmanuelle bernheim
était connu dans son milieu et de ses
proches évidemment elle travaillait dans
le cinéma
moi je la connaissais pas
personnellement et c'était une personne
très appréciée
évidemment on a un petit peu le poids de
sa dollar semble en tout cas que les
proches ne soient pas déçus on va trahir
les foires n'a rien à voir c'était
vraiment par rapport à ça en même temps
un film c'est une chose à part entière
voyez c'est un objet est une oeuvre à
part entière qui ne doit se préoccuper
que de lui-même en fait et c'est pas un
documentaire sur emmanuelle bernheim
s'est pas un biopic sur elle non plus tu
as donc on a aussi des
des libertés mais ça c'est ça c'est à
ozone s'occuper de sa vengeance ou lui
il a voulu lui être fidèle
parce que c'est aussi son histoire c'est
sa vie c'est comme elle le raconte
ll est le personnage est l'auteur du
film et voilà on a eu beaucoup de
retours de ses proches et jeu et je
crois qu'ils se sont se sont pas sentis
ni trahi ni mal aimés et au contraire
ils ont été très émue de l'hommage de
françois van vous avez une justesse de
jeu incroyable dans ce film vraiment que
c'est l'un de vos plus beaux rôles on
sent que vous avez envie de vous
abandonner quoi dans ce rôle ah bah oui
tronçon moi si je fais pas confiance aux
metteurs c'est dramatique quoi et à
partir du moment où on fait le top là on
y voit ce qu'il veut c'est vraiment mais
parce que
c'est lui qui a la vision c'est lui qui
kivu cadres et là en l'occurrence il est
vraiment dans la caméra en plus quoi
c'est le premier spectateur c'est lui
qui sait ce qu'il veut faire de son fils
est ce que faire ce film ça a été
quelque chose de cathartique pour vous
tous les films ne sont un petit peu on a
des plaies g comme on dit des terrains
de jeux qui sont très thérapeutique
finalement moi je considère que j'ai
énormément de chance de pouvoir exprimer
les choses et qu'on me demande
d'ailleurs même de les exprimer parce
que si je pouvais pas le faire aussi
l'image le frais ou dans une salle de
sport auquel matin faut y aller à son
patron c'est difficile à sa prof
donc on a on a finalement peu l'occasion
de de sortir ses émotions de dire aux
gens les films c'est toujours des mamans
d'une cour il faudra compter beaucoup de
choses donc on a une espèce de
concentrer comme ça de des événements de
vie d'émotion doublage toujours que
c'est une très très bonne thérapie
franchement vous êtes en sélection à
cannes avec avec cette dernière prévoit
thérapie le sopi de françois ozon pour
la première fois depuis toute cette
immense carrière que vous avez comment
est ce que vous le vivez ça représente
quoi pour vous c'est un présente une
continuité une célébration jeu très fier
c'est pas mon genre mais là je me dis là
c'est qui fait un peu quand même pu vite
parce que c'est très intimidant aussi je
vous avoue que quelques jours avant j'ai
un peu flippé quand même des vrais
besoins
ce que je vais dire tout ça journalistes
les petites phrases les machins à la
mauvaise photo et qui ont donné faut
lâcher parce que on peut pas tout
contrôler est d'ailleurs faux pas
surtout pas
et puis se dire que c'est quand même une
célébration et un partage pas ce que
c'est on montre le film est finalement
voilà on a envie que ça quand même
et puis surtout je vous êtes quand même
chaque année l'actrice préférée des
français
en français on vous aime tellement c'est
beau de voir que vous avez encore des
des petites doute de pouvoir du stress
avec autant d'amour pour à tour de vous
ouais c'est vrai ça aide beaucoup dans
la vie non mais c'est vrai c'est pour ça
que j'ai toujours envie de dire aux gens
entourez-vous d'amour et donner de
l'amour parce que ça facilite quand même
beaucoup les choses
après on peut être accro à saïdia j'ai
moins d'amour de s'embraser mais j'aime
like à mon dieu ma vie en dépend c'est
compliqué il ya toujours des jauges à
l'époque est compliqué les toc est
compliquée mais elle est changeante donc
moi je j'ose espérer que c'est pour un
mieux quoi merci beaucoup merci et merci
tu te rends compte qu'on est en train
folie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la place
[Musique]